[Music]
Google referendum and you'll find
hundreds of people explaining why
referendums are bad don't work Orientis
Democratic as they seem
but referendums are very much like the
way political life worked in the
birthplace of democracy ancient Athens
ancient Athenians didn't have
representative democracy they had direct
democracy with the electorate voting on
pretty much everything basically
never-ending referendums even at the
time democracy which is Greek for ruled
by the people had its critics not least
Plato teacher of Aristotle and one of
the most famous thinkers in history
[Music]
Plato thought democracy was terrible the
second worst form of government after
tyranny about 2,400 years ago Plato
wrote one of the first and most
influential books about government the
Republic in it play to imagine Socrates
his teacher concluding that the best
form of government is aristocracy which
is Greek for rule by the best he
imagined a well-educated aristocracy
that spent their lives being prepared
for leadership so that they could make
wise decisions for society though his
views were undeniably classist Plato
thought these aristocrats would rule
selflessly and virtuously but Plato
believed this ideal society would be in
constant danger of breaking down he
thought the sons of the wise educated
men would be corrupted over time by
privilege and leisure they would come to
care only about wealth and the
aristocracy would become an oligarchy
Greek for rule by the few these new rich
penny-pinching rulers would be obsessed
with balancing the budget austerity
would rule the day and inequality would
increase as wealth inequality in the
oligarchy grew the uneducated have-nots
would end up hugely outnumbering the
haves eventually the oligarchs would be
overthrown
and the state would collapse into
democracy meaning endless referendums
once the people had freedom they'd want
even more they want to take back control
sovereignty freedom at any cost would be
their single-minded aim it would be mob
rule so Plato would probably give
referendums a thumbs down but we have
all sorts of things that didn't exist in
Plato's time a representative democracy
the Supreme Court the Human Rights Act
universal education Plato wouldn't
recognize any of these checks against
thoughtless mob rule but we do and we
have these safeguards even when we have
a referendum so is Plato even relevant
is there anything to learn from a 2000
year old democracy hater I think there
is if we look deeper and ask why he
thought what he did what was so good
about how the aristocrats ruled and so
bad about the people in his imagination
plato's selfless aristocrats made wise
and educated decisions aimed at virtue
they asked themselves what would be the
just and prudent course of action the
uncultured have-nots let their passion
guide their decisions their love of
freedom for freedom's sake with little
thought of what was just or best drove
them so that's the key for Plato make
just prudent wise decisions let virtue
and not passion rule
[Music]
you